dear innovators how are you do you ever
think that by a professional holding a
diploma in agriculture or just to be a
sega culture card Agricultural Extension
officer but not a professional holding
village is an incredible extension what
is an extension what is an extension
service what is extension education what
is a negative Israel extension extension
research what are these why it is needed
to study extension from where it came to
our context why we need to study all
these yes all such questions will be
clarified within 10 minutes in this
video I am dr. Sarah Chandra welcome to
the channel agree innovators every
agricultural University in India must
perform three important roles education
research and extension education is to
develop and produce agricultural
professionals to develop agricultural
sector research is to encounter various
challenges occurs while agriculture
sector development extension is to cue
knowledge of Agriculture and its
technologies to the people who actually
practices agriculture like farmers let
us take the extension dimension of the
university and discuss in detail
extensions in the broader sense it is
called extension service this service is
an educational intervention Extension
Service Providers educates the farmers
about new methods of practices new
approaches for the profit and various
useful agricultural information along
with the educating the farmers here the
extension service providers can also
supply them with various agricultural
inputs credits etc look at to the
pictures provided here here some of the
scientists they are supplying farmers
with the new technology of poultry
housing
and they are supplying to the farmers
here one of the scientists is explaining
the farmers various diagnostic methods
and identifying the particular pests in
a particular crop and here another
picture where Agricultural Extension
officers they are trying to demonstrate
various agriculture technology for the
paddy to the farmers but who will do
this Extension Service Agriculture
officers aggregate all extension
officers rural developmental officers
private sector development officers
scientists at kvk dart centers sometimes
estin professors scientists when they
visit adopted villages or any field
visits like that and occasionally the
students in the reveille program
sometimes NSS programs may visit the
fields and they can perform this
extension service till now we have
covered one of the dimensions of
extension that is Extension Service
still two more dimensions of extension
are there they are extension research
and extension education let us see
extension research in detail what is an
extension research and who will do this
extension research we are going to see
observe the list of focus areas of
research of extension with the help of
extension research we can identify the
best methods of transfer of Technology
and we can study the adoption behavior
of the farmers and we can identify the
farmers interests so these suggestions
and their requirements and we can
identify the suitability of a particular
technology to the farming community
feasibility any of any particular
technology and we can identify the
different case studies and we can report
success and failure stories the most
important thing is that we can forecast
the technology and we can forecast the
research requirements from the farmer
side as well as from the state for
different stakeholders of the
agriculture sectors and we can give that
particular information to the
and who will do this extension research
they are extension specialized
scientists at receiving me and kandra's
and dart centers regional agricultural
research stations agriculture of
colleges and PG and PhD students of
Agricultural Extension let us consider
another dimension of an extension that
is extension education here again two
things are there one one thing is there
the extension expert is equipping the
agricultural professionals to perform as
extension service providers in the
future again those extension service
providers are involving farmers for the
transfer of Technology these two things
are comes under Agricultural Extension
education so teaching of extension
science to the agricultural
professionals as well as agricultural
science to the farmers both things comes
under extension education now tell me
which subject is more important economy
it is targeting the plants how to grow
the crops entomology is targeting on the
pests pathology is targeting on the
pathogens and breeding see technology
these are targeting about the seeds
plants like that but extension is
targeting the farmers and their
prosperity
I'm not saying extension is the only
subject is meant for the farmers with
the along with all the subjects
extension is also playing a very crucial
role to the development of agricultural
sector actually we should not compare
subjects like these one should have its
own role for the development of
agricultural sector we have to consider
each and every subject is very much
important for the farming community so
how can we define extension education it
has n number of
nation's because it has a very wide
range of dimensions out of all
definitions I have picked up a common
simple definition for extension
education look at that extension
education is a professional method of
non-formal education to bring desirable
changes in knowledge skills attitudes
and understanding of the rural people to
improve their social economical and
psychological status we need to
understand it is a non-formal education
and it is an educational intervention
and here we are focusing on the socio
economic and psychological standards of
the people the term extension we have
given meaning for the term extension in
India is transfer of Technology but here
we can observe different meanings of an
extension in Dutch it is called go
reaching in Malaysia it is called short
arch UK it is an advisory work Germany
enlightenment USA education Austria
furthering Korea rural guidance France
vulgarize ation spain capacities ation
so we have we can give different
meanings for the term extension but in
india we have given a meaning for the
extension is transfer of technology so
that we are mostly concentrating on the
transfer of agricultural technologies to
the farmers through extension let us
speak about some of the facts about
extension it has started not from the
agriculture universities like this it
has started in as a university extension
during 1867 actually availability of the
knowledge and generation of new
knowledge with the help of research is
only consumed within the university
vicinity but during 87 it has felt that
what is the fate of outside university
people so they should also get
benefitted with the university knowledge
so their first time
steps towards extending the university
knowledge to the rural community has
started from there the concept extension
has came into the picture nowadays we
are adopting this extension subject for
the agriculture horticulture veterinary
fisheries forestry daily home sales etc
in India so first time in Britain the
term extension has been used as
university extension the person behind
that / University Extension is James
Stewart we can call him as father of
university extension or the father of
extension during 19th century like in UK
in USA also extension term has been used
in the form of extension education the
person behind this extension education
is JP Liggins he is also treated as the
father of extension education and the
father of agricultural extension so far
we got to know the origin of an
extension where it actually came into
the picture and how we have been adopted
that particular extension to various
disciplines and we have understand
different roles of an expert's related
to the agriculture as well as extension
and we have to perceive extension is a
educational interface to empower people
further we are going to learn extension
education process Kris principles
objectives and scope of extension
what we can expect from this course the
basics of extension education basics of
communication because communication is
the essence of Education basics of
teaching methods knowledge on adoption
of an innovation basics on capacity
building agricultural journalism recent
approaches of Agricultural Extension
like there thank you